j'en rêve une vraie plaie des mains bien
ferme ce geste remonte au 5e siècle
avant jésus-christ à l'époque les
agressions à l'armé blanche étaient très
fréquentes
pour rassurer un interlocuteur on avait
donc pris l'habitude de tendre la main
pour les liens créés qu'elle était vide
petit à petit les mains en finit par se
coucher pour matérialiser l'élevage sur
certains bas-reliefs grecque
ici il s'agit d'une stèle tombale on
voit déjà des hommes se serrer la main
par ailleurs on sait qu'au moyen-âge les
chevaliers utilisé entre eux ce film
pour montrer qu'il n'avait pas de
mauvaises intentions
il tendait la main droite parce qu'à
l'époque automne l épée de la main
droite
cette même main droite que l'on se
serrait encore il y a quelques semaines
mon petit doigt me dit que ce n'est pas
prêt de recommencer
en attendant peut-être que l'on peut
pour se saluer tirer la langue comme le
font certains moines tibétains avec un
masque pas sûr que ça serve à grand
chose surtout pas se toucher login / mot
célèbre hongrie maori reste le signe de
la tête
c'est ce que font les chinois dans la
vie courante et ça pourrait bien devenir
contagieux ce concept capsule de vie
confinée
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo et le
chant de l'oiseau
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
vous pouvez également voir ou revoir les
vidéos des jours précédents en cliquant
sur le côté gauche jean publie une
nouvelle chaque jour alors pour être sûr
de ne louper aucune et bien abonnez vous
et activer la petite cloche à demain
n'oubliez pas nous sommes toujours
confiné mais on reste en lien par un
oiseau